acquiring professional certificates can
be quite time consuming it can take
quite a lot of effort to get them so
today in this video i want to inquire
the question what the most important
certificates for business professionals
really are so welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel from learning
my name is heinrich i'm a former
mckinsey consultant and on my channel i
talked about how to become successful in
the first years of your career so this
video is informed by my six years in
consulting having seen lots of companies
in that time and i also asked you on
instagram to get your opinion what the
most important certificates are and why
so all of this has been gone into this
video but to get some clarity of what it
is that i'm talking about let's mention
four areas that i will not cover in this
video and the first are very regular
university degrees something like a
bachelor master and mba this is not what
i will talk about this is not what i'm
considering a certificate same is true
for professional certifications that you
just need to work on a specific job this
for instance is a bar exam in law i'm
also not including a cpa or an acca or
any other accounting certification like
that next i will not consider
certifications that are very specific to
it so sap certification certifications
from google and finally i will also not
include certifications that are very
specific to just one sub area of
business something like a cpim and
supply chain or cma in accounting and
again exception will be those that are
more broadly recognized and applicable
all that being said let's jump here into
our tier list here with the s tier being
the highest tier and the dtr being the
lowest tier here in the rank that we are
going to do now let's start with
certifications from platforms like
udacity or coursera and so on and those
from your platforms where you do get a
certificate to a structured online
course and there is some type of
examination logic in the end where not
everyone necessarily gets a certificate
that goes over the curriculum and i'm
placing these types of certificates in
the sea tier and my rational here is
that yes often you learn quite a lot of
things it can be really helpful it also
must have once took a udacity course and
i did learn a lot of things from that
though the truth is i would still argue
that these types of courses are not that
respected by employers there's not
really the perception behind it that you
have such a certificate you're already
an expert in this field you really
accomplish something significant if you
passed so yes you will learn good things
but no i do not think that this will
make a huge impact on your career next
let's talk about scrum master
certifications and for the uninitiated
the scrum master is a role in the agile
methodology often used for instance in
modern software development i place this
in the seat here for the reasons that on
one inside this is i think a skill that
is not that narrow i think you can apply
agile methodologies in many different
areas in business not only for instance
software development and i do think that
the sole trend towards moving to agile
is very valuable and many businesses
cherish this and value this and
especially this idea of being a scrum
master is something with some positive
connotation tied to it there's several
quite renowned institutions where you
can do a scrum master certification as
long as you pick one of them i don't
think you'll make huge steps in your
career only because of that but i think
it is very much worth checking it out
quite similar to the scrum master i see
the six sigma belt certifications so
this is a principle often applied in
production it is about process quality
it is about continuous improvement and
this is something that i think many
people know many people know about it's
a system where you start with a white
belt and then you can advance up to a
black belt i think the last one is a
master belt it is something that many
people know i think the six sigma
principles are very well applicable in
many different types of business outside
of production as well and people will
respect it if you say that you're a sick
sigma black belt next to talk about
language certifications like the turfer
like the ielts tesla certifications
where you prove that your language
abilities meet a certain level and these
types of certifications actually often
require to get for instance into master
degrees also into mba programs the
reason why i put them into the details
not that they are worthless surely can
help to prove we have one of these
certifications and then of course you
would like to have a nice high score to
make you make use of it it's nice to use
this to prove that your english skills
are really meeting very high standards
but the truth is also especially for
these high-paced career roads in ib in
consulting if you apply to a firm like
mckinsey bcg bane people will just
assume that you have very good english
skills it's not really something where
people will test you for some consulting
firms do decide to have just an english
component in one of the interviews where
they just converse with you in english
to see whether you're up to the level
but if you pass this usually you will
get the checkbox and then it doesn't
really matter how high exactly your turf
score was in the end next let's talk
about the pmp the project management
professional certification this is a
certification where you prove that you
have project management skills that you
can lead teams understand what
stakeholder management is all about
master the common project management
skills and abilities and this is one
where i said this is very well known
well respected people will know usually
what this is and then on the other hand
there's also the fact that in almost all
modern business roads there will be some
type of project management expected from
you this is surely true and consulting
but also if you work in industry project
management is just part of almost every
modern business role which is i believe
it is just very important very relevant
and also quite well respected so this
should justify the a tier for the pmp
certification and now let's talk about
another certification that i would place
in the eight year and this is the case
score the candidate select score
and candidate select is actually the
sponsor of today's video so what are
they solving put yourself into the shoes
of a student you started one of the
prestigious target business schools and
maybe your score in the top 10 percent
of your cohort and this prestigious
target business school but are you not
just in general in the top 10 percent of
business students well likely not likely
you're much better right like your
personal time will be much higher
because of course there's already a
pre-selection of students attending this
specific target business school it
wouldn't be fair to compare yourself to
another person the top 10
of maybe a non-target business school
and these are exactly the considerations
that case wants to solve with their
certification program because case is
the provider of a fair and objective
evaluation of university degrees both
for students and also for employers and
they do this by collecting lots of great
distributions for many many universities
and degrees and combine this with over
400 000 data points of iq tests and
personality tests to algorithmically put
all the grades in the right context so
with case you can get a certificate as
the proof of your actual academic
performance above and beyond just the
absolute great and the truth is that
many companies including boston
consulting group kearney airbus tyson
group among many others they respect the
certification actually encourage
applicants to apply with this
certification to the job the case
certificate is currently offered for
eight different countries this includes
germany china india italy portugal spain
uk and usa so if you're interested for
the certificate case provided the link
for the from learning community where
you can actually get the basic version
of this certificate completely for free
just exit it via the link in the video
description the free version already
gives you a basic understanding where
you fall into the adjusted grade
distribution some basic statistics
around that and if you want even more
insights this opportunity to get a
premium certificate for a small
additional sum next let's talk about
certificates from online learning
platforms like udemy or skillshare i
personally like these platforms quite a
lot i also personally took many courses
on these platforms and i'm actually also
offering some of my basic courses on
these platforms as well the reason why i
put them here in the detail is that
actually i think while you might learn a
lot of things it's not really respected
in the employer market and the reasons
that often these certificates do not
really have proper examination
structures and this for me is the
difference comparing these certificates
to certificates from platforms like
udacity or coursera where there are
proper exams in the end these types of
examinations just do not happen for
these types of online degrees which is
why employers can already trust that you
have the skills and of course the
quality of these courses can also differ
quite a lot depending on the instructor
that you follow which is why i think the
details justified next let's talk about
the cfi and specifically the fmva
certification which is the financial
modeling evaluation certification and
yes this is a quite industry specific
function specific certificate the reason
why i'm mentioning this is that because
i think that many people actually know
it also just beyond the world of finance
it just shows that you have analytical
skills it shows that you are good in
excel good and modeling good and data
analysis which is why i think that this
is actually something worth mentioning
and many people also from the community
on instagram told me that yes they know
about the certification and they failed
that really helped them in the
application process which is why
included it here in the b tier let's now
talk about certifications from business
schools these are certifications that
are recently in the last one or two
years also see lots of ads on business
schools seem to promote these
certificates quite extensively you can
do certificates on all types of
different topics general management
finance blockchain crypto sustainability
and so on and often they're quite
renowned universities behind it offering
them and then in a couple of weeks for a
couple of thousand euros or dollars that
you need to pay you will get their
certificate and let's now start talking
about certificates that are offered by
non-target schools so proper
universities but not really target
schools and frankly here i think these
types of certificates are not that
different from certificates from
platforms like udacity coursera the
universities are not that renowned yes
there will likely be solid content
because it comes from an established
university or there's also some type of
examination structure in the end which
is why i decided to put them here in the
same tier here in the seat here and
let's contrast that from exactly these
certificates that are now offered from
target business schools so certificates
may be offered by harvard business
school by stanford by wharton any of
these other very renowned business
schools i think content wise maybe
they're a little bit better maybe not
who knows where it probably depends on
the specific degree of course now you
have the advantage of having this
reputation this big brand name on your
cv which maybe makes your cpu
a little bit more frankly though i think
that there's a very significant
difference comparing such a certificate
that you maybe make at harvard comparing
it to a proper bachelor degree at
harvard to proper mba at harvard how
this will be perceived is just very very
different and the main reason is that
everyone will know that you just paid
yourself into it usually it's really not
difficult to get into these certificates
you just need to pay a couple of
thousand bucks and then you can do it
you can write exams in the end it's not
really considered to be a big
achievement to have done that you might
learn some good interesting things and
yes it might give you a little bit of a
plus on the cv but don't expect that
only because you do that this will
really move your career forward in a
significant way that's at least my
humble opinion let me know in the
comments if you made any other
experiences on that next let's talk
about the gmat the graduate management
ability test and this might be a little
bit of a controversial choice but i do
think it's justified to put the gmat in
the eight year and maybe first for the
uninitiated the gmat stands for general
management admission test it's an entry
exam that is required for many advanced
business degrees including almost all
renowned mbas and it consists of
different sections integrated reasoning
we need to make sense of information is
presented to you quantitative skills we
need to do quant exercises and also
verbal logic exercises that you need to
do so first of all i did the gmat as
well when preparing for the gmat for my
mbas actually i did learn a couple of
things i would argue that my quorn
skills did improve quite a bit just by
preparing for the gmat in a structured
way actually made a video in the past
about my gmat journey i will link it
somewhere above your check it out if
you're interested on that but i do think
that a strong gmat score and of course
the value of the gmat will be very much
determined by the score is a very strong
indicator towards employers and i do
think it can help you to get the job get
that interview invitation and it's so
secret that many consulting firms
actually asking in their application
forms for your gmat score if you took
one that will want to know what your
score was but of course don't make
yourself illusions here if you have a
score that is below 650 for instance as
a gmat just to provide a couple of
ballpark numbers
this will likely more hurt you than help
you and then probably from 650 to 700
that's like nah you know it's like not
really good not really that strong
nothing that will really help you to
necessarily get invited if you score 700
or higher this i'd say usually would be
considered a good score a solid score
well it will definitely not hurt you
potentially that will also really show
your analytical abilities your
intellectual aptitude but i'd say to
really impress someone to really impress
someone with your gmat score you need a
score of 740 750 ideally or even higher
and then this will put you in the top
one percent top two percent top three
percent of the test takers this is where
you can really impress people with and
if you do score above the 700s then i
would argue for many many positions this
will help you quite a lot now let's talk
about the one certification that i would
put into the s tier and this is the cfa
the chartered financial analyst and yes
this is a certification that is of
course based on one industry on one
function and the finance function and it
is also true that actually you can only
hold this certification in the end if
you work for i believe in four years or
so in this area of business before that
you will not even get it but i would
argue you don't even need to have the
full final cfa in the end just the fact
that you completed a cfa level one for
instance or level two or level three so
three levels of exams you need to take
level one level two and level three and
then at least this is i believe how it
works if you have level three and also
meet these other requirements like
having a certain amount of work
experience you will get the title if you
just have the first levels this already
shows that you have very good finance
skills very good analytical quantitative
skills and the truth is almost everyone
in the business community knows the cfa
just a very very respected certification
frank if i look also at my former
colleagues at mckinsey what
certifications they did frankly none of
them had a pmp at least as far as i'm
aware almost none of them worked maybe
with a scrum master or six sigma belt
besides maybe the people really working
in the specialized practice in this area
but if you would look at the cvs of
these people quite a few of them had
actually cfa's completed or at least the
first levels this is very common the
truth is also that the passing rates
actually the failure rates of these safe
a levels are quite high for these
certifications about fifty percent five
zero i believe for the first level even
up to sixty percent six zero of the
people fail just showing that there is a
certain rigor behind it that not
everyone gets that you really need to
prove your worth show what you are able
to do but now all that being said do i
think that you really need these
certifications to succeed in business to
advance your career of course it's
difficult to give black and white
answers on that it might also depend on
the environment the company that you
apply for but i'd argue especially if
you apply for consulting role it's also
for investment banking so these that say
traditional high-paced careers
actually these certifications are not
really needed i can promise you you will
not get hired because you have these
fancy certifications on your resume if
at all if you have a very high gmat or
maybe a strong cfa of course this can
help this can underline your analytical
aptitude but i've never in my whole life
overheard any people say oh this person
this guy this lady such a strong person
just to look at his or her impressive
certifications this is just not how it
works so take all of this with a grain
of salt of course also this ranking it's
not a science just my personal judgment
let me know in the comments what your
perspective on that is very open to
engage in a conversation with you what i
think is a nice little offering is the
case course certificate that i talked
about the firm that is actually also
sponsoring this video once again you can
download your personal case certificate
in the most basic version for free check
out the link in the video description to
get access to that it is quite respected
by several employers and available in
many countries so as always if you took
any value out of this video at all
destroy the like button subscribe turn
on the notification bell big big thanks
to all the members of this channel much
appreciated my name is heinrich you'll
find weekly videos here on my channel
see you again next week until then all
the best to you and bye